Non pensavo sarebbe stata così dura ragazzi
Qualcuno mi aiuti ciao mariners oggi voglio rovinarmi
In che senso voglio rovinarmi marina spiegaci meglio allora io direi che pe spiegarvelo meglio posso prendere soltanto due cose da questo tavolo
acqua micellare e dischetti struccanti
Secondo me adesso inizierete a capire
Mi voglio rovinare perché oggi voglio provare insieme a voi tutte le mie tinte  labbra una dopo l'altra
Ebbene si ragazzi e ragazze ebbene sì è arrivato il momento di fare questo video
Che praticamente sono sicura che alla fine. Del video e non mi sentirò più
Le labbra a forzare struccarmi che adesso un rossetto news quindi non è niente di grave ma
quando avrò la tinta labbra tipo nera
Parliamone se devo essere sincera se devo essere sincera non sono tutte le mie tinte labbra
Perché se no penso che il video sarebbe durato dai
60 agli 80 minuti quindi ho selezionato insomma quello è un po più particolari o quelle chiuso di più
alcuni non le ho mai messo tra l'altro e
Siete pronti forse non riesco neanche a provare tutte queste perché ovviamente sono
Che
Qualcuno mi aiuti qui davanti a me ho le mie fantastiche di intel a bra
Che sono della dx o della caf con gi. Oh di max o di nabla
partiamo subito iniziamo con le tonalità un po meno impegnative quindi coni miur
partiamo con il niger I
libri o 4 che sia questo il numero
Carina
Ma non avevo mai messo questo
Dovete sapere che tanti insomma me le mele danno da provare quindi può essere che alcune non
avviene anche mai aperte voto da 1 a 10 fatemelo sapere nei commenti
Rimanendo sul mood passiamo a ritmo nel di nabla
Chiaramente ragazzino, ne sto mettere tutte precise sennò finiamo più
Questa è una di quelle che metto più spesso è veramente molto molto carino ecco che inizia il patatrac
Nota mi, sa che dopo sto video la devo ricomprare la quale genera grande
micellare cioè la fedele micellare domiciliare
Parlante da solo milan cosa proviamo
Sempre di nabla klose
Simile alla prima no
Un po più su rosino
Passiamo la tonalità un po più decisa questo l'ho messo due tre volte devo dire all'estate
Forse I rari myers se lo ricorderanno questa è top
Io adoro
By
Rosso scuro
Vabbè questo l'ho messa un pò veramente la cavolo
E sarà anche molto difficile da togliere però il colore carinola
Notiamo anche il rossore intorno a molto fashion dobbiamo barbie
Forse l'ho messo una volta questo anche perché un colore altamente impegnativo
Già inizio per le labbra fucsia e non per la tinta labbra che procediamo con bell azzurro busco questo è un altro
Molto molto molto sobrio forse non. L'ho mai messo questo l'avevo comprato così pre sfizio
Chi sia non. Lo so tra. Gli oggetti
Allora dopo l'azzurro buffo devo dire che non. Ho più. Non mi sento più. Le labbra ma proseguiamo perché io non mi arrendo
Adesso proverò la prima tinta labbra di ma che ho provato ai tempi era insomma la tonalità più più richiesta infatti all'andata anche fuori produzione
Con c'è ancora un po di azzurro non fateci caso quanto è bella e mi ero innamorata
Non sono tutto fucsia
a proposito di fucsia
togliamo questo dell'aics
Carino
Adoro siamo solo a
129 dentro
Mi sembra una vita che li prova o provi a questo partito non. Ho mai provato forse
nabla analisi
è tipo
da grigio viola grigio
Un po drammatico hulk
Iron man e il problema ti rimane tra. Le pieghe a
Cura dei denti a che
passiamo un altro colore molto sobrio un bel viola metallico oscuro
Così un po un po alieno dai non è malvagio vi piace o no
Tolgono
Creare quasi metà della l'inps non. So come definirlo direi che è un bel rosso acceso
Lasciamo perdere come questo
Mi piace
Mi non sono nostre esprimermi io vi amo tantissimo ma non. So se riuscirò a provarne ancora molte
Perché ho già le labbra tipo vanno a fuoco con questo bellissimo di carbon di outlaw
Top
Torniamo alle dalle tonalità un po più
Sobria a quest'altro quali cocktail di double dee ce l'ho messo anche un sacco
Questo anche molto carino un po pesca vediamo questo mix
Il video di oggi va vedere maryna che prova quasi tutte le sue tinta labbra facendoci vedere tutti i suoi colori e dicendoci come si chiamano e quelli che li piacciono di più. Mirraccomando guarda il video e segui maryna su Facebook, Instagram e musical.ly ma soprattutto metti mi piace e segui il canale, un saluto al prossimo video .❤️
libri o 2x l'idv in questo nuovo paesaggio visto farfa questa carino no
Vediamolo
Adesso proviamo un marrone scuro questo qua di hicks
Lcl 32
scurissimo questo
Colore topo ecco l'ho definita così questa finta labbra
La rimetterò sicuramente spesso le labbra non esistono pur non. Le sento più
Non pensavo sarebbe stata così dura ragazzi paghiamo gli ultimi colori perché I ragazzi tutti questi li ha trovati
stiamo scherzando
allora questo qua di nabla grace
Come la bimba di più
Carino notare che ho ancora il grigio qui voglio morire
Molto molto molto carino questo lo metterò più spesso devo continuare ragazza roth è stata una mia idea cioè capito
il problema
Ai dai che ci siamo quasi con gli ultimi
allora
torniamo a caso fondi con questo
a 15
Devo fare metà e metà
risparmiamo tempo e
Le mie labbra non. Vanno a fuoco
Metà questo messa
Sempre di kat von d beloved
Carino questo duo mi piace
Non riesco nuovo canone
Non riscosso reader mi tirano le labbra tremenda
proseguiamo con un altro connubio questo connubio e di nabla è un lato mettiamo alter ego
Dall'altro mettiamo bad boy
Un po tipo di duetto di giovanni rana una parte un colore da una parte l'altro
Quale preferite. I due fatemelo sapere nei commenti sia prima auto le discussioni sotto questi commenti perché insomma vi. Ho fatto 4 miliardi di domande
Dei ragazzi ormai c'è un utile non va. Via in rosso quindi
così adesso pure sul naso
Questo di nabla, zen
Non trovate che siano buffissimi a volte I nomi di chiedere tinto labbra broadway queste cose
Beh sembra fossi messo in maniera decente
Sono anche carino non provo l'ultimo di kat von d del codice ai ragazzi li ho fatti chiude la metà quindi sono stata più
brava
Incredibile ma vero ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta li contiamo insieme
1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8
10 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 23
Ragazzi 23 ho trovato 23 tinte labbra solo per voi, non
ho più praticanti no 24 questo governo fino al 24
Non, ho più insomma
sensibilità per quanto riguarda le mie labbra
Dischetti ne abbiamo da collezionare appendere al muro e spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
Chiaramente ce ne sono tanti altri tinte labbra. Nella mia make up collection
magari faccio anche la make up collection si dirà e
Fatemi sapere quale tinta labbra vi è piaciuta. Di più o quali sono le tinte labbra che mi sono piaciuti di più
Lasciandomi un commentino qua sotto e come al solito se non l'avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al mio canale e cliccate la campanella che trovate vicino alla tassa d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
Aggiornati su tutti I miei video e come sempre seguitemi, su tutti gli altri social instagram facebook e musicali vivendo un bacino con queste labbra
belle gonfie e doloranti
e li voglio tantissimo bene